.
Australien.
Sven Furrer auf Abwegen
abseits der bekannten Pfade.
Australien,
das Land der Superlative.
Ein Land, ein Kontinent.
Die Australier behaupten, nirgends
lebe man so glücklich wie Down Under.
Alles ist tatsächlich viel grösser,
welliger, gefährlicher,
herziger -
aber macht das wirklich glücklich?
We will see -
12'378 km durch Australien.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Alice Springs, meine Reise
beginnt bei 46 °C im Schatten.
Boah!
Zum Glück habe ich
die Lederjacke dabei.
Lago mio, ist das heiss!
Ich bin zum ersten Mal in Australien.
Ich wusste, es wird heiss. Aber
diese Hitze hatte ich nicht erwartet.
Und das bekannte Alice Springs
ist viel kleiner, als ich dachte.
Meine Reise
beginnt im Zentrum Australiens,
d.h., mitten im Herzen
des roten Kontinents.
Ah, meine Güte!
Abenteuerliche Rockmusik
Noch nie war ich
so weit weg von zu Hause.
Und ich bin auch kein Reiseprofi,
im Gegenteil: kein Bedarf.
Wenn es nach mir geht,
ist die Schweiz
das glücklichste Land auf Erden.
Nein! Ich kann nichts anfassen.
Hopp!
Internationale Studien sagen aber,
dass die Bürger Australiens
die glücklichsten der Welt sind.
Ich kann es mir
fast nicht vorstellen.
Ich will die Menschen kennenlernen,
die sagen:
"Uns geht es am besten und wir sind
die Glücklichsten der ganzen Welt."
Mein Forschungsgebiet ist riesig.
Entsprechend sind auch
die Dimensionen meiner Reise:
12'378 km in 70 Tagen.
Mit meinem Kamerateam reise ich
fast um den ganzen Kontinent -
von der Wüste ans Meer,
vom Zeltplatz in die Grossstadt,
über Autobahnen und Naturstrassen,
auf Umwegen und Abwegen.
Abenteuerliche Rockmusik
Verdammter Luftzug!
Du hast den Scheibenwischer drin!
Ich weiss, aber ich kann ...
Lachen
Ja, aber ich weiss nicht,
wie man ihn abschaltet.
Ich muss mich voll konzentrieren,
damit ich links bleibe.
Alles ist verkehrt.
Abenteuerliche Rockmusik
Unterwegs bekomme einen Eindruck
von der Grösse dieses Kontinents.
Diese unglaubliche Weite,
das Gefühl der Grenzenlosigkeit.
Ist das der Schlüssel zum Glück?
Heute lerne ich jemanden kennen,
der von sich sagt,
er habe den besten Job der Welt.
Er heisst Dale Campbell,
und sein Arbeitsort ist das Outback,
die Wildnis in der Mitte Australiens.
Treffpunkt
ist die Ranger-Station
des Nationalparks
der West MacDonnell Ranges.
Guten Morgen,
ich suche Dale Campbell.
Du bist Dale? Freut mich.
Ich bin Sven vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Schön dich zu treffen.
Gehts gut?
Ja, klar.
Du zeigst mir also heute dein Revier?
Ich verstehe Dale fast nicht.
Er spricht leise, wirkt unsicher.
Trotzdem spüre ich seinen Stolz,
mir sein Outback zeigen zu dürfen.
Dale ist Aboriginal,
ein Ureinwohner Australiens.
Ich darf ihn heute
durch seinen Arbeitstag begleiten.
Das Outback ist für Dale
nicht bloss ein Arbeitsort.
Er ist Mitbesitzer
von diesem Land.
Das Land, das seit Jahrhunderten
seinem Stamm, den Arrernte, gehört.
Als Ranger
auf seinem eigenen Land zu arbeiten,
ist eine besondere Ehre
und macht ihn stolz und glücklich.
Das ist also
das Land deiner Familie?
Ja, das ist mein Land.
Meine Familie,
meine Onkel und Tanten,
meine Grosseltern leben hier.
Die Häuser da drüben
gehören deiner Familie?
Ja, die gehören meinen Tanten.
Als kleiner Junge
wuchs ich hier draussen auf.
Aus dieser Erfahrung heraus
kam der Wunsch, Ranger zu werden.
Diese Hügel
rauf- und runterzukrabbeln,
das hat mich geprägt.
Als ich älter wurde,
habe ich erkannt,
wie wichtig dieses Land
für uns Aborigines ist.
Aber heutzutage leben die Aborigines
doch meist in den Städten?
Und du willst raus aus der Stadt?
Ja, nach den ersten Jahren
hier draussen,
verbrachte ich fast
mein ganzes Leben in der Stadt.
Jetzt will ich hier raus ziehen,
in die Landschaft meiner Kindheit.
Das ist meine Lebensaufgabe,
dieser Landschaft Sorge zu tragen.
Dafür sind wir Ranger ja da.
Nachdem ich meine Mutter
verloren hatte ...
Du hast deine Mutter verloren?
Ja, vor 6 oder 7 Jahren.
Sie starb an Krebs.
Mir wurde klar, dass ich mein Leben
jetzt in die Hand nehmen muss
und einen guten Beruf brauche,
um für meine Familie
sorgen zu können.
Und jetzt habe ich wohl einen
der besten Berufe, die es gibt.
Sanfte Gitarrenmusik
Dale ist verheiratet
und hat 2 Kinder.
Noch lebt er
mit seiner Familie in Alice Springs.
Sein Wunsch wäre aber,
dass seine Kinder hier draussen
in der Natur aufwachsen.
Das ist also das echte Outback.
Ja, das ist der Busch.
Die Ausbildung zum Ranger
ist anspruchsvoll.
Der Beruf geniesst
in Australien hohes Ansehen.
Dale ist einer
der ganz wenigen Aborigines,
die es geschafft haben.
Sanfte Gitarrenmusik
Welche Fliegen meinst du?
Die hier.
Die grosse?
Ja.
Die stechen?
Ja, die hier versucht es gerade.
Das sind Stechfliegen.
Die tauchen meist
nach einem grösseren Regen auf.
Wenn sie dich stechen,
juckt es höllisch, wirklich übel.
Mit dem musst du hier
in dieser Hitze leben.
Ist das Trinkwasser?
Ja, das ist das Trinkwasser
für die Wanderer.
Du kannst mir helfen
mit dem Schlauch.
Wir schieben ihn unter das Netz.
Im Sommer steigt das Thermometer
hier bis auf 50 °C.
Die natürlichen Wasserquellen
sind ausgetrocknet.
Wassertanks wie dieser
haben schon manchem Wanderer
das Leben gerettet.
Dort drüben auf dem Ast,
siehst du sie?
Dale hat eine Eidechse entdeckt.
Während der Kameramann sie filmt,
murmelt Dale plötzlich,
er fühle sich gar nicht gut.
Bist du okay?
Geht schon. Da haben mich wohl
zu viele Fliegen gestochen.
Bist du sicher,
dass es die Fliegen sind?
Ja, glaube schon.
Tut es weh?
Ja, an einigen Stellen schmerzt es.
Und im Gesicht?
Ich spüre,
dass mein Gesicht langsam anschwillt
und ich mehr schwitze als sonst.
Nimm das hier!
Zum Glück habe ich ein Antiallergikum
in der Reiseapotheke dabei.
So schlecht habe ich mich
in den 20 Jahren hier draussen
noch nie gefühlt.
Wenn du willst, kann ich dich
zur Ranger Station zurückfahren.
Ist schon okay,
ich kann selbst fahren.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, es ist nur dieser Juckreiz,
der so unangenehm ist.
Aber ich kann sicher
alleine zurückfahren.
Wir müssen
die Dreharbeiten mit Dale abbrechen.
Er besteht darauf,
alleine zurückzufahren.
Immerhin hat er ein Funkgerät dabei.
Vielen Dank für den tollen Ausflug.
Sei vorsichtig auf dem Heimweg!
Ja klar.
War wirklich schön mit dir.
Und pass auf dich auf!
Gute Fahrt.
Ja.
Bye-bye.
Und so bereite ich mich alleine
auf die erste Nacht im Outback vor.
Eigentlich hatte ich erwartet,
Giftschlangen würden
meine grösste Sorge sein.
Boah!
Ich muss mein Zelt schliessen.
Diese Fliegen sind so mühsam ...
Schau einmal!
Die sind so aggressiv.
Sie stechen zu.
Ich bin ganz zerstochen.
Das ist grauenhaft.
Und es hat Millionen
und Abermillionen davon.
Das ist wie ein Nest.
Schau mal!
Igitt!
Er schreit laut auf.
Himmel noch mal!
Sanfte Musik
Die Stechfliegen
rauben mir den Verstand,
und es ist unerträglich heiss.
Das kenne ich
von den Walliser Bergen nicht.
Als ich mich später
bei Dale versichere,
dass er gut nach Hause gekommen ist,
meint er lachend am Telefon:
In Australien müsse man sich
das Glück eben erkämpfen.
Er sei das beste Beispiel dafür.
Ich bekomme hier einen Eindruck, was
die Faszination Australiens ausmacht:
die Weite
und das Gefühl von Grenzenlosigkeit.
In der Nacht waren die Stechfliegen
dann endlich weg.
Doch die Bruthitze blieb.
Geschlafen habe ich wenig.
Leichte Banjo-Musik
Mein erster grosser Reisetag -
und bereits vor dem Mittag
habe ich 340 km auf dem Zähler.
Da, da gehts zum Ayers Rock.
Am bekannten heiligen Berg
fahre ich zügig vorbei.
Ich begebe mich auf Abwege
und suche das Australien
abseits der Klischees.
Ich habe jetzt über 1'000 km auf dem
Zähler, und langsam wird es dunkel.
Die einzige Siedlung weit und breit
ist William Creek.
Ein Pub, ein Motel, eine Tankstelle
und einige Blechhütten.
Einwohneranzahl: 5.
Hello!
Hello, good evening.
Adriana von der Tankstelle
hat für uns hier angerufen
und Zimmer reserviert.
Mich hat sie nicht angerufen,
aber das kriegen wir schon hin.
Rose!
Sven lacht.
Und ihr geniesst das Feierabendbier?
Ja.
War es streng heute?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Hi.
Hallo, wie gehts?
Adriana hat dich angerufen
und Zimmer reserviert.
Mich?
Keine Ahnung, wen sie angerufen hat,
aber sie sollte Zimmer
für uns reservieren.
Ich habe keine Reservation.
Aber ich habe freie Zimmer.
Für eine Nacht?
Ja, nur eine Nacht.
Sanfte Gitarrenmusik
William Creek
ist eine Oase für Reisende.
Nach einem langen Tag
in der Bruthitze
geniesse ich ein kühles Bier,
ein deftiges Nachtessen
und v.a. eins:
Boah!
Eine Klimaanlage. Aber sofort.
Rauschen der Klimaanlage
Husten
Am nächsten Morgen lerne ich
den zahmen Dingo Bert kennen
und seinen Besitzer Trevor Wright.
Ein sympathischer Typ,
knorrig und unterhaltsam.
Ihm gehört nicht nur das Pub
und das Container-Motel,
ihm gehört das ganze Dorf.
Ich bin der Sekretär,
der Gemeinderat,
der Feuerwehrkommandant,
bin zuständig für die
Stromversorgung und das Wasser.
Ich mache alles
vom Chef bis zum Hilfsarbeiter.
Und wenn nötig,
helfe ich in der Küche
und putze die Hotelzimmer.
Man muss wirklich vielseitig sein.
Ich sitze nicht einfach im Büro
hinter meinem Computer
und habe nach 8 Std. Feierabend.
Ich bin 7 Tage die Woche
24 Std. im Einsatz.
So ein Dorf
ist wirklich ein harter Job.
Ich habe oft gelesen,
Australien sei das Lucky Country,
der glückliche Kontinent.
Einverstanden?
Ich finde,
wir können uns glücklich schätzen,
dass wir so viel Platz haben,
alle dieselbe Sprache sprechen
und alle
die gleichen Chancen im Leben haben.
Wir haben Gemeinschaftssinn
und helfen einander.
Im Outback ist dieser Gemeinschafts-
sinn besonders ausgeprägt.
Nur wenn wir einander helfen,
können wir hier draussen überleben.
Trevor zeigt mir sein Reich -
natürlich im Auto.
Denn ohne Klimaanlage
hält man die Mittagshitze nicht aus.
Vor einigen Jahren
hat er zunächst dieses Pub gekauft.
Danach kam ein Gebäude nach dem
andern dazu, meistens spottbillig.
Irgendwann
gehörte ihm das ganze Dorf.
Ich sage dir, hier draussen
zu leben, prägt den Charakter.
Do you wanna come inside
and we keep rolling a little bit?
Fahr einfach da hoch!
In der Wellblech-Hütte da drüben
steht unser Generator,
der das ganze Dorf versorgt.
Geradeaus?
Ja.
Ich zeige dir, wo ich lebe.
Das ist das einzige Stück Rasen
im ganzen Dorf.
Und das ist mein Schloss
mit Swimmingpool.
Wie ist es,
hier draussen alleine zu leben?
Du bist nie wirklich
alleine hier draussen.
Ich bin ständig beschäftigt,
mit dem Hotel, mit all
den Unterhaltsarbeiten im Dorf.
Gut, und du hast ja viele Leute,
mit denen du plaudern kannst.
Aber ein richtig persönliches
Gespräch gibt es da doch nicht.
Nein.
Weisst du, hier draussen musst du
wirklich selbstständig leben können.
Wenn du das nicht kannst,
hältst du es nicht aus.
Im Outback musst du
hart im Nehmen sein -
sonst treibt dich
die Wildnis in den Wahnsinn Ð
die Hitze, die Fliegen, der Dreck.
Trevor betreibt auch einen Flugplatz.
Hier treffe ich die junge Frau,
die mich im Pub bedient hat.
Sie heisst Talia Sheppard
und erzählt mir,
sie sei die Chefpilotin
der lokalen Airline.
Ihr Geschäft
seien Touristenflüge ins Outback.
Abenteuerliche E-Gitarren-Musik
Eine Pilotin, die nebenbei
an der Rezeption arbeitet.
Sie müsse wohl ganz schön
vielseitig sein, frage ich Talia.
Ja, so ist es.
Du musst wirklich vielseitig sein.
Du musst
eine gute Mechanikerin sein,
musst gut mit Menschen
umgehen können.
Wir haben viele Touristen,
die hier vorbeikommen.
An der Rezeption?
Genau.
Kochst du auch?
Ja klar.
Wirklich?
Das ist okay so. Alle machen alles.
Langweilig wird es bestimmt nie.
Talia erzählt mir,
ihr Freund sei auch Pilot.
Sie sähen sich viel zu selten.
Aber die Ferien
verbrächten sie immer zusammen.
Von Australien
sehe sie im Berufsalltag genug.
In den Ferien wolle sie
den Rest der Welt sehen.
Warst du schon einmal
in der Schweiz?
Ja, ich habe ein Jahr lang
in der Schweiz gelebt.
Nein, wirklich? Wo?
Ich ging in Wohlen zur Schule.
Und ich habe
an 3 unterschiedlichen Orten gelebt:
im kleinen Dorf Bettwil,
in Muri und in Cham.
In Cham auch?
Ich lebe in Zug, also in Baar.
Aha, da bin ich jeden Tag
mit dem Motorrad durchgefahren.
Hast du dort eine Schule besucht?
Ja, ich habe
ein Austauschjahr gemacht,
nachdem ich die Schule in Australien
abgeschlossen hatte.
Und ich habe in der Schweiz
Fussball gespielt.
Der Frauenfussball in der Schweiz
ist auf einem hohen Niveau.
Ich habe viel gelernt.
Du hast Fussball gespielt?
Ja, für Wohlen.
Dann trägst du sicher
weisse Socken wie alle Aargauer.
Nein, ich habe wieder
auf schwarze Socken umgestellt.
Talia bietet an, mich zu meiner
nächsten Destination zu fliegen.
Mein Kamerateam ist begeistert -
ich weniger.
Ein bisschen komisch
ist mir schon ...
Mein letzter Flug in so einem
Kleinflugzeug ist 20 Jahre her.
Thank you.
Er stöhnt angestrengt.
Sanfte Musik
Talia meint, der Blick von hier oben,
das sei australisches Glück.
Sie kenne nichts Schöneres.
Wir fliegen über den Lake Eyre,
einen riesigen Salzsee.
Dort unten liegt die Clayton Station,
eine Farm so gross wie das Tessin -
mit einer eigenen Landepiste.
Clayton Oldfield und sein Vater Shane
sind die Besitzer der Farm.
Sie sind typische Outback-Kerle:
harte Schale, weicher Kern.
Du bist der Sohn, Clayton.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ich bin Sven.
Wie gehts?
Gut, und wie ist das Leben
auf der Clayton Farm?
Kann mich nicht beklagen.
Das ist mein Vater, Shane.
Freut mich, wie gehts?
Gut.
Wie siehts aus? Trocken und heiss?
Es ist heiss
und es ist trocken, das stimmt.
Und viel Arbeit?
Allerdings, wir müssen die
Wasserlöcher für das Vieh füllen.
Und die Zäune
müssen repariert werden.
Klingt gut,
ihr habt also Arbeit für mich?
Keine Sorge,
wir finden schon was für dich.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal in Australien.
Seit einer Woche bin ich unterwegs.
Auf meiner Suche
nach dem australischen Glück
habe ich schon 1'300 km hinter mir.
Und jetzt bin ich
auf der Clayton Station.
Abenteuerliche Rockmusik
Ich begleite Clayton Oldfield.
Seit Generationen
bewirtschaftet seine Familie
eine typisch australische Farm
mitten im Outback.
Eine Farm,
so gross wie der Kanton Tessin.
Wie ist das Leben auf dem Land,
wo der nächste Nachbar
35 km weit entfernt lebt?
Auf ihrem Land
züchten die Oldfields Rinder.
Zusätzlich halten sie eine Herde
halbwilder Pferde.
Diese versuchen wir heute
zusammenzutreiben
mithilfe unserer 2-Rad-Pferde.
So, was ist der Plan?
Dort drüben
siehst du eine Staubwolke.
Das sind die Pferde.
Wir fahren gleich rüber,
um meinem Vater zu helfen.
Deinem Vater?
Ja, dort siehst du
das Licht seines Motorrads.
Er fährt
mit einigem Abstand zur Herde.
Er treibt die Pferde da rüber,
und wir schneiden ihnen dann
den Weg ab.
Ah, okay.
Entspannte Countrymusik
Es sind praktisch wilde Pferde.
Sie werden höchstens 2- bis 3-mal
im Jahr zusammengetrieben.
Es scheint fast so, als
würden wir das Glück zusammentreiben.
Die Tiere und die Natur
bestimmen das Leben auf der Farm.
Das erinnert mich
an meine Kindheit im Wallis.
It was great!
Clayton
trennt ein Pferd von der Herde.
Er hat das Tier an einen Pferde-
stallbesitzer in Perth verkauft.
I'm just gonna hold it there.
Clayton liess sich ein Jahr lang in
Kanada als Pferdeflüsterer ausbilden.
In solchen Momenten zeigt sich
der weiche Kern des coolen Cowboys.
Sie ist noch
ganz aufgedreht vom Zusammentreiben.
Ich muss sie zuerst beruhigen.
Ich spiele mit ihr und versuche,
die Bindung zu ihr aufzubauen.
Sie muss wieder
Vertrauen zu mir gewinnen.
Mithilfe einer raschelnden Plane
versucht er,
dem Tier
die Schreckhaftigkeit zu nehmen.
So bereitet er das Pferd
auf den Transport vor.
Bedeutet für dich Glück,
mit Pferden zu arbeiten?
Es ist eine Leidenschaft für mich.
Ich reite, seit ich 2 Jahre alt bin.
Mit 10 habe ich
mein erstes wildes Pferd gezähmt.
Ich bin mit Pferden aufgewachsen und
habe mit ihnen viel Schönes erlebt.
Ich fühlte mich Pferden immer nahe.
Ich liebe es, mit ihnen zu arbeiten
und neue Ziele
mit ihnen zu erreichen.
Es ist eine Leidenschaft.
Ganz klar.
Komm näher!
Du darfst dich nicht verkrampfen.
Sei so, wie du bist,
dann nimmt sie dich an.
Hast du Erfahrung mit Pferden?
Ja, mein Vater
hatte 20 Jahre lang Pferde.
Sie hat
keine Macken oder Ähnliches.
Sie hat einfach Angst.
Du musst also einzig
ihr Vertrauen gewinnen.
Lass sie dich kennenlernen!
Sie soll dich
mit beiden Nüstern riechen können,
denn jedes Nasenloch verarbeitet
unterschiedliche Informationen.
Halte sie an der kurzen Leine,
dann kannst du sie
besser kontrollieren.
Geniess es
und vergiss nicht zu lächeln!
Faszinierend!
Vorhin bin ich diesem Wildpferd
noch mit dem Motorrad gefolgt,
und jetzt kann ich es streicheln.
Komm!
Sanfte Gitarrenmusik
Mutterkuhhaltung ist Knochenarbeit.
Das Land der Familie Oldfield
ist enorm trocken und karg.
900 km Stacheldrahtzaun
halten die Kuhherden zusammen.
Es ist eine lebenslange Sisyphus-
arbeit, die Zäune instand zu halten.
Ob ich mich wirklich nützlich
machen kann, weiss ich nicht.
Clayton geniesst meine Begleitung,
denn es ist einsam hier draussen.
Also, hier bauen wir ein Gatter?
Ja, wir schweissen Verstrebungen
für ein Gatter.
Brauchen wir die?
Ja.
Wir können nicht schnell
in die Eisenwarenhandlung gehen.
Die ist 800 km weit weg.
Wir haben hinterm Haus
unseren eigenen Supermarkt
mit Sperrmüll und Altmetall.
Den durchsuchen wir,
wenn wir etwas brauchen.
Du musst dir zu helfen wissen.
Alles wird wiederverwendet,
nichts wird weggeworfen.
Das sind alte Wasserleitungen.
Clayton hatte grosse Pläne.
Er wollte mit seiner Frau
die Farm übernehmen.
Die Ehe ging aber in die Brüche,
und dieser Traum ist somit geplatzt.
Seine beiden Söhne
leben jetzt weit weg in der Stadt.
Das ist ein Thema,
über das Clayton nur ungern spricht.
Ich versuche es darum
mit einem lockeren Spruch.
Es muss ziemlich schwierig sein, hier
im Outback eine Frau kennenzulernen.
Ja, du läufst nicht gerade
täglich einer über den Weg.
Erst recht keinem
heissen Schweizer Girl.
Touristinnen?
Nein, die Auswahl ist bescheiden.
Du musst einfach jede Chance nutzen.
Hast du eine Freundin?
Nein, zurzeit bin ich Single.
Mir werden die Schattenseiten
des Outbacks bewusst.
Die Menschen haben hier zwar
die grosse Freiheit gepachtet,
es ist aber schwierig, einen Partner
zu finden, um das Glück zu teilen.
Sanfte Countrymusik
Diese seltsam weiss anmutenden Bäume
sind das Resultat
eines Buschfeuers von 2003.
Die Bäume sind nicht tot,
sie erholen sich wieder.
Man sieht, dass die Baumkronen
wieder leicht grün sind.
Mein nächstes Ziel ist Dalgety,
ein abgelegenes Nest
mit weniger als 100 Einwohnern.
Wenn es vor 110 Jahren nach dem
Willen der Politik gegangen wäre,
hätte es um ein Haar mehr Berühmtheit
erlangt als Sydney und Melbourne.
Hello?
Morgen, kann ich was fragen?
Ich habe keine Zeit, wirklich.
Nur 2 Min.
Stimmt es, dass Dalgety mal beinahe
die Hauptstadt von Australien wurde?
Ja, das war der Plan.
Wie kam es dazu?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich kenne nur die Bildlegende
von dem Bild da drüben.
Das ist das Foto
und die Bildlegende dazu.
Und das sind die Minister?
Ja, damals.
Und was machen die im Wasser?
Na, sie baden.
Um das Wasser von Dalgety zu testen?
Ich weiss nicht,
ich kann dir wirklich
keine Geschichte dazu erzählen.
Das sind Minister
der australischen Provinzen.
Sie suchten 1903 einen Standort
für eine gemeinsame Hauptstadt.
Sydney und Melbourne
waren damals Rivalen.
Die Minister suchten einen Standort,
der unabhängig dazwischen lag.
Da unten
ist die Fotografie entstanden,
die wir im Pub gesehen haben.
Schliesslich hat man sich
gegen Dalgety entschieden,
weil es einerseits zu weit
entfernt war von der Eisenbahnlinie
und andererseits fühlten sich die
Minister von Sydney benachteiligt.
Denn Dalgety liegt ein paar Kilometer
näher bei Melbourne, Sydneys Rivalen.
Sanfte Countrymusik
Man einigte sich damals auf ein
anderes Nest, das niemand kennt.
Oder wissen Sie es?
Canberra.
In der heutigen Hauptstadt treffe ich
meinen nächsten Gesprächspartner:
Urs Wälterlin.
Er ist Korrespondent
für das Schweizer Radio und Fernsehen
und lebt
seit vielen Jahren in Australien.
Es ist eine künstliche Hauptstadt,
ein wenig wie Brasilia in Brasilien.
Wir sitzen hier buchstäblich
auf einer Schafweide.
Canberra war einmal eine Schaffarm.
Jetzt sind wir wirklich
genau vor dem Parlamentsgebäude.
Hier wäre ein super Spielfeld ...
Es gibt kaum ein anderes Land,
das so gross ist und über
dessen Politik man so wenig weiss.
Im Vergleich zu Urs
passt mein Outfit eher
zur Schafweide als zur Staatspolitik.
Doch wer reist schon mit Hemd
und Krawatte durch Australien?
Urs ist mit einem Politiker ver-
abredet, der uns das Parlament zeigt.
Guten Morgen, Angus!
Wie geht es?
Guten Morgen.
Ich bin Sven.
Wie gehts?
Sehr gut,
wir haben es gefunden.
Es ist nicht so schwierig,
so ein riesiges Gebäude zu finden.
Es ist im Hügel versteckt.
Als das neue Parlamentsgebäude
1988 eröffnet wurde,
war es das teuerste Gebäude der Welt.
Es kostete
nicht weniger als 1 Mrd. Fr.
Das ist das Parlament -
150 Repräsentanten.
Die Regierung sitzt auf dieser
Seite, die Opposition da drüben.
Und die kleinen Parteien
irgendwo hier.
Und im Gegensatz zur Schweiz
geht es hier sehr laut zu und her.
Das ist ein Teil unserer Kultur.
Wir gehen direkt miteinander um,
das ist ganz typisch australisch.
Wir sehen es in diesem Parlament.
Die Debatten
hier sind berühmt-berüchtigt.
Einige finden das toll, andere
finden es schlicht unanständig.
Aber die Realität ist, dass dies
einfach zu unserer Kultur gehört.
Und was sind zurzeit
die grossen Themen im Parlament?
Es gibt verschiedene grosse Themen,
aber das mit Abstand wichtigste
sind die Arbeitsplätze.
Seitdem die Rohstoffpreise einbre-
chen und der Investmentboom abkühlt,
müssen wir schauen, wie
wir Arbeitsplätze schaffen können.
Das ist eine wirklich harte Debatte.
Als ich mich auf
diese Sendung vorbereitete,
las ich viel über das Lucky Country.
Wie sehen Sie das?
Nun, gewisse Leute übersetzen
den Ausdruck Lucky Country
als das Land, das Schwein
gehabt hat und so zu Wohlstand kam.
Wir hatten aber nie einfach Schwein.
Wir hatten stets
auch Probleme zu bewältigen.
Eine grosse Herausforderung zurzeit
ist die Wirtschaftslage.
Unsere Arbeitslosenquote steigt.
Wir haben mit dem Rohstoffboom
an Konkurrenzfähigkeit eingebüsst.
Wir müssen das Glück
wieder in die Hand nehmen.
Wir nehmen die Welt so,
wie sie ist.
Wir machen unser eigenes Glück.
Wir passen uns den Realitäten an und
packen die Probleme pragmatisch an.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie Familie Wälterlin lebt.
Wir fahren aufs Land.
Das ist ...
Extra fürs Schweizer Fernsehen!
Grossartig!
Und das Grössenverhältnis
ist sehr passend.
Urs Wälterlin träumte schon
in seiner Jugend von einem Bauernhof.
Heute betreibt der Journalist
in Gundary eine Hobbyfarm.
My home is my castle, was?
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Das ist Wombat Creek.
Mit Hund, dem Moritz.
Eier aus Eigenproduktion?
Ja, genau.
Urs und Christine
lernten sich vor über 20 Jahren
in Australien kennen und lieben.
Mit ihren damaligen Partnern
waren sie in Australien in den Ferien
und liefen sich
zufällig über den Weg.
Es war Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Das ist so unser Gehöft, sozusagen.
Unser Grundstück.
Dazu gehört der Berg da auch,
und es zieht sich da nach hinten
und hier hinunter.
Es hat eine etwas spezielle Form:
Es sind eigentlich
3 Grundstücke, total 134 ha.
Habt ihr denn das Grundstück und Haus
so gekauft, wie es jetzt ist?
Überhaupt nicht.
Wir bauten alles selber.
Ausser den Zäunen gab es hier
noch keine menschlichen Spuren.
Wir fingen hier wie viele Australier
mit einem kleinen Wohnwagen an.
Etwa hier, wo das Haus ist.
Dann stellten wir
einen grossen Wohnwagen hin,
weil die Familie wuchs. Und dann
wurde es im Wohnwagen zu kalt.
Denn hier kann es weit unter 0 °C
werden, das wissen viele nicht.
Australien ist nicht immer heiss.
Dann wurde es also zu kalt - wir
hatten auch keinen Strom und nichts.
Darum begannen wir
mit dem Bau dieses Hauses.
Sind deine Wurzeln jetzt hier?
Meine Wurzeln sind in der Schweiz,
ich bin Schweizer.
Ich bin ein Schweizer,
der in Australien lebt.
Ich lernte im Verlauf der Zeit,
zu sagen,
dass man dort zu Hause ist,
wo die Menschen sind,
die man am liebsten hat.
Dort ist man zu Hause.
Es ist eigentlich egal,
wo man wohnt,
ob in der Schweiz oder 18'000 km
entfernt hier in Wombat Creek.
In der Nachbarschaft
hat sich herumgesprochen,
dass Urs Besuch
vom Schweizer Fernsehen hat.
Also Urs, was erwartet uns da?
Es erwartet uns eine ganz normale,
nachbarschaftliche Party.
Ein australisches Barbecue.
Und das findet im Shed,
im Gartenhäuschen, statt.
So, da sind die Leute.
Hello!
Das ist Mick.
Hallo, Mick.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Bei diesem heissen, australischen
Wetter habe ich immer so Durst!
Sehr gut, das gefällt mir!
Sven lacht.
Vielen Dank.
Cheers.
Nochmals danke für die Einladung!
Urs.
Ist das jetzt ein typischer Shed?
Ja.
Was zeichnet so einen aus?
Typisch ist, dass alles
von Männersachen dominiert ist.
Je weiter man sich
von den Grossstädten entfernt,
desto mehr ist der Shed
wirklich eine Männerdomäne.
Als ich vor 20 Jahren hierher kam,
war es sogar so,
dass bei solchen Partys die Frauen
und Männer praktisch getrennt waren.
Die Männer waren in einer Ecke
und tranken ihr Bier,
während die Frauen
in der Regel in der Küche waren
und dort ihre Dinge diskutierten.
Heute dürfen die Frauen dabei sein.
Sie dürfen sogar mit Fremden flirten.
Hello.
Hallo. Ich bin Julie.
Hallo. Ich bin Sven.
Wie heisst du?
Sven.
Schöner Name!
Wirklich? Danke.
Er ist anders.
Eigentlich rede ich nicht mit Leuten,
deren Namen ich nicht kenne.
Mick und Julie
sind unsere wichtigsten Nachbarn.
Ist die Nachbarschaft wichtig hier?
Ja. Wenn man so im Busch lebt,
können gewisse Dinge passieren.
Das Erste ist das Feuer.
Es herrscht immer Feuergefahr,
ausser, wenn es wie jetzt regnet.
Aber wir sind umgeben
von Eukalyptuswäldern,
also von Feuergefahr.
Man muss zueinander schauen.
Das ist nachbarschaftliche Pflicht.
Und eben, es kann ja
auch mal was passieren,
z.B., dass jemand
von einer Schlange gebissen wird.
Dann muss man halt helfen.
Dann muss man reagieren.
Alright. So we're gonna join
a bit of wire on.
Es wird ein langer
und lustiger Abend.
Irgendwann beschliesst
Urs Wälterlins Freund, Brian Cox,
mir das Zäunen beizubringen.
Das kann ja nie schaden.
Lektion 1: Der Achterknopf.
Von unten hoch, durchs Auge.
Oben drüber und runter,
oben durch und wieder runter.
Und dann so.
And you go ...
Jetzt sieht es aus wie eine 8.
Du bist also der Zaunprofi
in der Gegend.
Ich baue nun seit 60 Jahren Zäune.
Zum Gaudi der ganzen Nachbarschaft
bin jetzt ich dran:
das Greenhorn aus der Schweiz.
So, und dann?
Oben durch und zu dir hin.
Straighten it a little.
Untendurch und obenrum.
Wieder untendurch
und zurück hier durch.
Drück ihn noch etwas runter!
Aha. Hier muss ich rein.
Fest zurückziehen. Fest!
Schau dir mal den Achter an!
Wie aus dem Lehrbuch.
Thank you very much.
No worries.
Weiter gehts in die Blue Mountains,
nach Katoomba.
1 Std. westlich von Sydney.
Das Städtchen lebt wie viele
andere Destinationen vom Tourismus.
Die Gäste kommen wegen der Natur -
immer noch
das wichtigste Kapital Australiens.
Sanfte Gitarrenklänge
Morgen treffe ich den Ururenkel
eines bekannten Engländers,
der vor 178 Jahren hier stand,
die Natur bewunderte
und eine Idee hatte,
die die Welt veränderte.
Schau, er kommt!
Ich lerne einen schrägen,
aber sehr sympathischen Vogel kennen.
Du siehst aber startklar aus.
Wie bist du denn unterwegs?
Menschen bestiegen in diesen
Kleidern den Mount Everest.
Und wer ist das?
Das ist Mathew, ein Wildhuhn.
Chris Darwin ist der Ururenkel
des bekannten Charles Darwin,
Begründer der Evolutionstheorie.
Chris setzt sich für den Schutz
bedrohter Arten ein.
Warum bist du
mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs?
Ich will meinen ökologischen
Fussabdruck möglichst klein halten.
Ich will herausfinden,
was die Australier von ihrem
bekannten Besucher Charles Darwin
heute noch lernen können.
Sein Ururenkel Chris zeigt mir
die eindrücklichen Wentworth Falls
in der Nähe von Katoomba.
Charles Darwin
erkundete diese Gegend 1936
im Rahmen
einer mehrjährigen Expedition.
Er glaubte wie alle damals
fest daran,
dass Gott die Menschen
und die Natur erschuf.
Hier an diesem Ort
bekam dieses Weltbild aber Risse.
Er wanderte hier runter
und sah diese fantastische Aussicht.
Hier entstanden
die ersten kritischen Gedanken,
die später in der faszinierenden
Frage mündeten:
"Was sind wir? Stammen wir von Affen
ab oder erschuf uns Gott?"
Charles Darwin hielt in seiner
Autobiografie sein Denken fest.
Er schrieb:
"Meine goldene Regel lautet:
Schenk jenen Fakten
besonders viel Aufmerksamkeit,
die deinen Überzeugungen
widersprechen."
Das war seine goldene Regel.
Ich denke, das ist das Wichtigste,
was wir heute noch
von ihm lernen können.
Überleg dir, was er da sagt!
Selbstverständlich neigen wir dazu,
alles zu ignorieren, was
unseren Überzeugungen widerspricht.
Darwins Grundhaltung macht das Leben
absolut faszinierend.
Denn plötzlich
hat dich alles zu interessieren:
Nichts ist sakrosankt,
du musst alles hinterfragen.
Das ist wohl das Wichtigste,
das ich von ihm gelernt habe.
Er hat viel verändert.
Du hast auch viel verändert,
du hast dein Leben verändert.
Erzähl mir etwas darüber!
Viele von uns hatten schon
dunkle Zeiten im Leben.
Ich auch.
Ich versuchte,
mir das Leben zu nehmen.
Grosse Sache.
Natürlich kannst du danach
nie mehr derselbe sein.
Was hat sich verändert?
Nun, davor war ich nur an Geld
und materiellem Erfolg interessiert.
Ich merkte aber, dass mir Geld nicht
das geben konnte, was ich brauche.
Darum wurde ich Bergführer
und versuchte, ein fröhliches,
optimistisches Leben zu führen
und nicht mehr nach
materiellem Reichtum zu streben.
Chris machte früher
gutes Geld als Werber.
Sein Glück aber fand er in der Natur.
Sven, hier wirds nass.
Und wir laden alles ab?
Ja, Rucksack runter
und Neoprenanzug anziehen.
Das ist der erste Sprung.
Weil das Wasser nicht tief ist,
musst du rückwärts springen.
Rückwärts?
Ja.
Ist es sicher?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Freudig-stolzer Ausruf
Ist das schön hier!
Hier gibt es Süsswasserhummer.
Wollen wir einen fangen?
Ja, klar.
Die können dich
ganz schlimm zwacken.
Wirklich?
Ganz schlimm.
Lass dich nicht erwischen!
Er versucht es gerade.
Oh!
Sven lacht.
Jetzt bist du dran.
Er kann mit den Scheren
weit nach hinten greifen.
Au!
Versuch, die Hand
so flach wie möglich zu halten!
Wir machen es so:
Ich halte ihn vorsichtig mit dem
Stock und du kannst ihn nehmen.
Hast du ihn?
Halt ihn gut fest!
Du tust ihm nicht weh.
Und jetzt die Hand
ganz flach halten. Sehr gut.
So what do you reckon?
Das ist ein australischer
Süsswasserhummer, ein Yabby.
It'll jump back in.
Be careful it doesn't get you!
Oh!
Das war aber knapp.
Ich dachte schon,
er gebe dir einen Abschiedskuss.
Es ist beeindruckend, mit welcher
Begeisterung und Unbeschwertheit
Chris Darwin der Natur begegnet.
Sanfte E-Gitarren-Musik
Chris ist überzeugt, dass man mit
positiven Erlebnissen in der Natur
bei den Menschen einen viel
nachhaltigeren Effekt erreicht,
als wenn man mit Moralisieren
auf ein schlechtes Gewissen pocht.
Wunderschön, diese Schlucht.
Und das Abseilen am Schluss
ist der Höhepunkt.
Das ist das Sahnehäubchen
des Canyonings.
Sehr gut gemacht!
Du warst super.
Good! Fantastic.
Schau das Lichtspiel! Wunderschön.
Familie Darwin lebt in der kleinen
Ortschaft Glenbrook.
Chris ist ein Naturfreak.
Seine Frau Jacqui
ist PR-Beraterin in Sydney
und bezeichnet sich selber
als City Girl.
Ihr Haus ist der perfekte Kompromiss:
2 Schritte hinter dem Sitzplatz
beginnt ein regelrechter Urwald.
Poor old Ally. It's not good.
So. What have we got?
Who wants some coffee?
Wie passen ein Naturfreak und eine
PR-Beraterin aus der Stadt zusammen?
Auf den ersten Blick sind Chris
und Jacqui ein kurioses Paar.
Beim Frühstück merke ich aber bald,
dass sich hier 2 Gegenpole gefunden
haben, die sich bestens ergänzen.
Wie steht es mit dem Umweltschutz
in Australien?
Muss schwierig sein.
Alle reden nur
vom Wirtschaftsboom im Moment.
Die Umweltverschmutzung ist gross.
Australien hat einen grösseren
ökologischen Fussabdruck
als die meisten europäischen Länder.
Eigentlich
als die meisten Länder der Welt.
Wir könnten noch vieles verbessern.
Ökologisch sind wir
ein weniger glückliches Land.
Ist der Klimawandel
für euch erwiesen?
Für mich ja. Es muss dringend etwas
geschehen, meiner Ansicht nach.
Australien hat bereits
ein extremes Klima.
Wir haben zwar nicht so extrem tiefe
Temperaturen wie ihr in Europa,
aber extrem hohe Temperaturen
und heftige Stürme.
Das wird immer schlimmer
und unangenehmer.
Nahrungsmittel werden teurer, und
es wird viele andere Folgen haben.
Aber ich denke,
wir Menschen ticken halt so.
Solange man nicht direkt betroffen
oder besonders selbstlos ist,
unternimmt man nichts
gegen den Klimawandel.
Ihr Ziel ist es, Ally, Monty und
Razzy für die Natur zu begeistern,
damit sie nicht wie andere Kinder
Stunden vor dem Computer verbringen.
Ich darf beim allmorgendlichen Ritual
dabei sein.
Und schnell merke ich,
dass sie das nicht nur machen,
weil das Fernsehen dabei ist:
Die Kinder kennen alle Vögel,
die hier im Wald leben.
There's one!
Sven, sie werden dir aus der Hand
fressen. Setz dich hierher!
Jungs, seid ihr bereit?
Schau, dort!
Wir müssen alle ruhig sein,
dann kommen sie runter.
Du musst ganz ruhig sein.
Sven pfeift.
Er geht wieder.
Keine Sorge, er kommt zurück.
He did it!
Sehr gut, du bist geduldig.
Ja, ich bin halt ein Vogelflüsterer.
Vogelflüsterer und Hummerflüsterer.
You're good at this.
Beautiful job.
Wie fühlt sich das an, Sven?
Grossartig.
Ich versuche,
jeden Tag so zu beginnen.
Die Idee dahinter ist:
Wenn man mit einem positiven Gefühl
in den Tag startet, kommt alles gut.
Dieses Bild würde
dem grossen Charles Darwin gefallen:
Sein Ururenkel,
der dem Schweizer Journalisten zeigt,
wie wenig es braucht,
um das Glück in der Natur zu finden.
Entspannte Banjo-Musik
Ich komme in Darwin an -
im tropischen Norden Australiens.
Diese Gegend ist berühmt-berüchtigt
für seine Salzwasserkrokodile.
Es kommt immer wieder
zu tödlichen Unfällen.
Nicht wenige würden die gefährlichen
Jäger am liebsten ausrotten.
Wie können Mensch und Krokodil
zusammenleben?
Einer, der das weiss, ist
Charlie Manolis, Krokodilforscher
und Chef-Wissenschaftler
im Crocodylus Park von Darwin.
Zuerst will er mir
ein Krokodil zeigen,
das letzte Nacht
im Crocodylus Park gestorben ist.
Es war das grösste Krokodil, das je
im Hafen von Darwin gefangen wurde.
Es ist also
ein ganz spezielles Tier.
Boah!
Meine Güte!
Für den Transport
haben Charlies Mitarbeiter
das tote Tier auf der Bahre fixiert.
Es war schon länger krank.
Letzte Nacht ist es gestorben.
Stell dir vor,
du begegnest so einem Tier
bei einem
romantischen Mondscheinbad.
Ich habe noch nie ein Krokodil
von so nahe gesehen.
Wenn dich ein Tier
von dieser Grösse erwischt,
hast du keine Überlebenschance.
Aber sie sind
ein Teil unseres Lebens.
Ein wichtiger Teil.
Stimmt.
Die Menschen hier im Norden
müssen mit diesen Tieren leben.
Es geht also darum,
die Population so zu kontrollieren,
dass die Menschen
die Tiere akzeptieren.
Du kennst das
von den Wölfen in der Schweiz.
Die Bauern wollen sie nicht,
weil sie ihre Schafe reissen.
Die Krokodile fressen Vieh, Büffel,
Menschen - sie fressen alles.
Unsere Herausforderung
besteht darin,
die Öffentlichkeit dazu zu bringen,
dass sie diese Tiere wollen.
Wir mussten die Tiere
also irgendwie wertvoll machen.
Das kann Tourismus sein
oder die Zucht.
Wir haben jetzt
ein nachhaltiges Programm.
Wir haben zahlende Touristen
in unserem Park.
Wir haben eine Fleischindustrie,
exportieren Krokodilhäute.
Das schafft Arbeitsplätze.
Krokodile sind also wertvoll.
Sven, das ist unser Inkubator.
Da haben wir normalerweise
bis zu 12'000 Eier drin.
Leider bist du
zum Ende der Brutsaison hier.
Aber du kannst mir trotzdem helfen.
Okay.
I get you
to carry this out for me.
Hey, schau sie dir an!
This one you can see here ...
Oh, sie wollen abhauen.
Wir tun sie ins Becken.
Die kommen aus der Wildnis -
vom Adelaide River, 60 km von hier.
Pass auf,
dass sie dich nicht beissen!
Die können beissen?
Oh, ja.
Sie kommen mit 68 kleinen Zähnen
aus dem Ei.
Es ist unglaublich.
Sie finden immer den
empfindlichsten Teil deines Fingers.
Siehst du die kleinen Zähne?
Ganz vorne oben,
den kleinen, weissen.
Den meine ich.
Das ist der Eierzahn.
Ah, okay.
So kann er das Ei öffnen.
Du siehst, alle Zähne sind schon da.
Sie sind scharf. Sie beissen.
Ich habe
keinen Kugelschreiber dabei.
Die beissen dich problemlos blutig.
Du kannst eines halten.
Unglaublich!
Die Haut ist so weich.
Kaum zu glauben, dass so etwas
Niedliches mal 6 m lang wird.
Abenteuerliche Countrymusik
These are another different type
of breeding pen.
Die Zuchtstation des Krokodilparks
ist für die Öffentlichkeit gesperrt.
Charlie und sein Team müssen ein
grosses, männliches Tier einfangen.
Es wird im Zoo das Krokodil ersetzen,
das letzte Nacht gestorben ist.
This one here.
Ah, okay.
John wird versuchen,
ein Seil über sein Maul zu werfen.
Aber bist du sicher,
dass da nur eines drin ist?
Ja, ja.
Jungs, sucht alles genau ab!
Check the other pond, guys! How much
of a gap is there beyond that fence?
Passt auf, wenn es hochkommt!
Es wird sehr schnell sein.
Vor wenigen Minuten
hat mir Charlie erzählt,
dass es keine Überlebenschance gibt,
wenn dich so ein Krokodil attackiert.
That's it! That's it!
Hoffentlich machen die das
nicht zum ersten Mal.
Komm in Sicherheit!
It's alright.
Das Krokodil versucht,
sich zu befreien,
indem es sich
um die eigene Achse dreht.
Grauenhaft!
Man merkt den Zug.
Er macht nur eine kleine Bewegung
und zieht dich fort.
Come on!
A couple of people,
just pull him up!
Achtung, jetzt kommt er in die Nähe.
Der ist ja riesig!
Mir ist nicht mehr so wohl.
Jetzt ist er
1,5 bis 2 m von mir entfernt.
Okay.
Es ist ziemlich aufregend.
Er lacht nervös.
Der Kopf ist 50 cm von mir entfernt.
Und ich halte das Seil,
das ihm das Maul zuhält.
Ich hoffe, die anderen halten auch.
Sonst halte nur noch ich.
Boah, meine Güte! It's close.
Wir binden ihm jetzt das Maul zu.
Das Krokodil hat unglaubliche Kraft
beim Zubeissen,
aber fast keine Kraft,
um das Maul zu öffnen.
Eine dünne Schnur reicht.
Jetzt ist es ganz ruhig.
Ja, aber sie haben diese Ausbrüche.
Sie sind sehr schnell erschöpft
und müssen sich erholen.
Und plötzlich
bäumen sie sich wieder auf.
Wenn er sich benimmt,
können wir glücklich sein.
Aber wir müssen immer aufpassen.
Der Hals des Krokodils ist so stark,
wir können es problemlos ziehen.
Passt auf das Bein auf, Jungs!
Carefully. That's it.
Zuerst war ich irritiert,
als ich den Bagger gesehen habe.
Nach meinen Erlebnissen
war mir aber klar,
dass man ein Tier mit einer solchen
Kraft nur so transportieren kann.
Und so bringen Charlies Leute
das Krokodil in sein neues Gehege.
Okay. One, two, three.
Go!
That's it.
It might walk through.
Hang on! Watch it!
Watch yourself!
It's coming through the fence.
Okay. Lift his back legs!
Lift his back legs!
Okay. Hop on him, someone!
Und nicht zu vergessen:
Hier drin ist noch eines.
Nicht zu vergessen!
Okay. Let him go.
Viele Australier
verteufeln Krokodile.
Dank Charlie Manolis und seinem Team
sind diese Tiere
in Darwin eine Attraktion,
die Arbeitsplätze schafft.
Wo Natur und Mensch
aufeinandertreffen,
können Konflikte entstehen.
Ich denke,
wir Menschen müssen akzeptieren,
dass es die absolute Sicherheit
nicht gibt,
und versuchen,
mit der Natur im Einklang zu leben.
Auf meiner Reise
wage ich mich auf einige Abwege.
Aber so lange war noch keiner.
Die Gibb River Road führt 660 km
mitten durch die Gegend
der Kimberley.
Gemütliche Musik
Die legendäre Überlandstrecke
ist nur in der Trockenzeit befahrbar.
Dann, wenn die Flüsse
wenig Wasser führen.
Wenn wir hier stecken bleiben,
einfach nicht aussteigen!
Hier gibt es Krokodile.
Und nicht wenige.
Die Sonne geht unter.
In 10-15 Min. ist sie ganz weg.
Ich muss jetzt noch
ein Nachtlager finden.
Und ehrlich gesagt: Ich bin ein wenig
unter Druck. Ein klein wenig.
Das ist der Vorteil des endlosen
und menschenleeren Outbacks.
Ich biege einfach von der Strasse ab
und fahre in unberührte Natur,
um zu übernachten -
weit weg von der Zivilisation.
Wo wäre das in der Schweiz
noch möglich?
So.
Und fertig ist mein Nachtlager.
Ruhige Klänge
Die endlosen Weiten des Kontinents
sind heute fast menschenleer.
Früher durchstreiften die Aborigines
dieses Land auf Nahrungssuche.
Mit der Ankunft der ersten
weissen Siedler vor 226 Jahren
geriet das Leben der Ureinwohner
aus dem Gleichgewicht.
So, das ist ein Privatgrundstück.
Ich nehme an, wir sind hier richtig -
schauen wir mal!
Ich habe mich
mit Neville Poelina verabredet.
Er lebt mit seiner Familie
im Oongkalkada Camp.
Neville gehört
zum Aborigine-Stamm der Nyikina.
Mit ihm will ich das Australien
der Ureinwohner kennenlernen -
das Leben in der Natur
und mit der Natur.
Gehen wir mal fragen!
Du musst Neville Poelina sein!
Ja, das bin ich.
Ich bin Sven,
schön, dich kennenzulernen!
Freut mich!
Wie geht es?Fantastisch.
Bei dem Wetter!
Sehr schön
und angenehm kühl seit 2 Wochen.
Wer bist du?
Ich bin Simon Poelina!
Aha, der Sohn.
Willkommen, ich bin Jo!
Sven, freut mich!
Die nächsten 2 Tagen werde ich
mit Nevilles Familie
in ihrem Camp mitten im Busch leben.
You're alright?
Yes, I'm okay.
Das Wasser, das du hier im Camp fin-
dest, kannst du bedenkenlos trinken.
Und Schlangen?
Lass die einfach in Ruhe!
Die kommen nicht, um dich zu
beissen, die haben Besseres zu tun.
Lass sie einfach vorbeiziehen,
und es gibt keine Probleme.
Bring kein Tier um,
das du nicht essen willst!
Das ist meine einzige Regel hier.
Wir leben in einer symbiotischen
Beziehung mit der Natur.
Dingos kommen vorbei,
wilde Truthähne.
Neulich steckte ein Strauss
seinen Kopf ins Auto rein.
Das ist also deine Unterkunft.
Sieht toll aus!
So I can open it here?
Yes.
Das ist wirklich wie im Himmel.
Like heaven!
Wenn du auf diesem Bett schläfst,
fühlst du dich wie im Himmel.
Das ist dein Bad.
Unter freiem Himmel das Geschäft
verrichten - grossartig!
In meinem Camp musst du dich
wie ein Familienmitglied fühlen.
Mit diesem Respekt
behandeln wir uns hier draussen.
Die nächsten Tage
gehöre ich zu deiner Familie?
Du bist mein Bruder.
Grossartig, bis später.
Der Stamm der Nyikina
kämpfte 9 Jahre lang darum,
als Besitzer seines traditionellen
Landes anerkannt zu werden.
Sie erkoren Neville
zum Hüter des Stammeslandes.
Mit den Einkünften aus dem Camp fi-
nanziert er den Unterhalt des Landes.
Es ist eine grosse Ehre
für meine Familie,
die Hüter dieses Landes zu sein.
Ich zeige dir heute,
wie glücklich wir sind.
Ich sehe es dir an.
Hier musst du einfach
glücklich aufwachen am Morgen.
Wenn nicht, bist du tot -
hier lebst du im Himmel.
Das Holz,
das meine Tochter Angelina trägt,
ist von grosser spiritueller
Bedeutung für uns.
Wir räuchern dich heute, um dich auf
unserem Land willkommen zu heissen.
Wir hüllen dich in den schützenden
Rauch, damit dir nichts passiert.
Und der Rauch wird
alle schlechten Geister vertreiben,
die du auf mein Land bringst -
die werden hier im Feuer bleiben.
Danach werden wir
einen fantastischen Tag haben.
Wir verwenden das Holz
von 3 unterschiedlichen Bäumen:
Eukalyptus,
Gungra-Busch und Papierrindenbaum.
Dieser Rauch reinigt uns
und nimmt alles Böse von uns.
Es riecht wirklich gut.
Ja, wunderbar!
Jetzt muss ich das Feuer ersticken,
damit wir den Rauch
richtig einatmen können.
Stand up in the fire!
Come back in the fire!
Thanks for the matches!
Sanfte Musik
Wir verbringen
den Nachmittag am Fitzroy River.
Neville legt grossen Wert darauf,
sein traditionelles Wissen
an seine Kinder weiterzugeben.
Angelina und Simon kennen alle
Pflanzen und Tiere in der Gegend.
Simon hat von seinem Vater gelernt,
wie man Barramundi angelt.
Heute ist der 9-Jährige mein Lehrer.
Kannst du mir helfen?
Ja.
Wie muss ich die Rute bewegen?
Wenn du den Köder einholst,
machst du immer ruckartig 1, 2, 3
mit kleinen Pausen dazwischen.
Dann sieht es aus
wie ein verwundeter Fisch,
der nicht mehr
richtig schwimmen kann.
Das lockt den Barramundi an -
er will einen einfachen Fang.
Wenn wir Glück haben, wirst du
uns heute Abend alle satt machen.
Ich versuche mein Bestes.
Viel Glück!
You're pretty good.
That's all you need to learn.
Als alle schon etwas gelangweilt
sind, gelingt mir der erste Fang.
Sven, hochziehen!
Das Netz!
Simon, you're ready?
Langsam, nicht ausrutschen!
Sven, lauf hier rüber!
Okay, geschafft!
Got him!
Wow, great!
Der Barramundi
ist ein begehrter Speisefisch.
Letzte Nacht las Neville die Sterne
und berechnete,
wann die Fische anbeissen.
Ich darf mir also nicht zu viel
auf mein Fangglück einbilden.
Another one!
Ja. Jedes mal, wenn wir uns
in der Natur bedienen,
zollen wir dem Tier,
dem Fisch unseren Respekt.
Und danken dem Land,
dass es uns ermöglicht hat,
Essen nach Hause zu bringen.
Es ist ganz einfach: Wir nehmen
unseren Schweiss aus der Achselhöhle
und streichen ihn auf den Boden -
wie eine Unterschrift.
Was sagen wir?
Danke für das Vergnügen
und die Barramundi!
Und danke, dass wir diesen Fluss
hinter unserem Haus haben.
Wir versprechen,
gut nach ihm zu schauen.
Galio yo mabu yo.
Neville sagt, die Natur sei
sein Supermarkt und seine Apotheke.
Hier finde er alles,
was er für seine Familie braucht.
Da drüben!
Das ist der Baum, den wir suchen.
Sehr gut
gegen Entzündungen und Prellungen.
Ich befestige den Plastiksack hier,
und du kannst mir helfen,
die Medizin zu pflücken -
für deine Familie,
du bist ja mein Bruder.
Du hältst den Ast so
und ziehst einfach die Blätter ab.
Nevilles Vorfahren leben seit über
60'000 Jahren auf diesem Kontinent.
Mit der Ankunft der weissen Siedler
wurden die Aborigines in ihrem
eigenen Land an den Rand gedrängt.
Neville, du nahmst dein Schicksal
in die Hand und hast etwas aufgebaut.
Warum schaffen das
nur so wenige Aborigines?
Ich frage dich:
Warum machen grundsätzlich so wenig
Menschen etwas aus ihrem Leben?
Nicht nur Aborigines.
Ich denke,
mein Volk muss jetzt handeln.
Sonst verpasst es den Anschluss.
Wir wurden 250 Jahre lang
kolonialisiert.
Wir müssen begreifen, dass der
Kontinent nicht mehr nur uns gehört.
Er gehört
den Schwarzen  u n d  Weissen.
Leider haben wir
eine weisse Regierung.
Und wir Aborigines
müssen uns den Weissen anpassen.
Die Aborigines tun sich schwer
mit der modernen Welt.
Viele haben Alkoholprobleme.
Sie ziehen in die Städte und
verlieren das traditionelle Wissen.
Ich denke, das ist
doch das Hauptproblem, oder?
Wenn du einem Menschen den Stolz
und das Selbstvertrauen raubst,
was soll er tun?
In all den Ländern,
die von den Weissen erobert wurden,
lebten stolze Menschen.
Doch sie wurden
zu lange unterdrückt.
Dieses Trauma
veränderte das Denken der Menschen.
Wir dümpelten 250 Jahre lang
in den Schwimmwesten herum,
die uns die Regierung
zugeworfen hat.
Jetzt sagt die Regierung:
"Hey, wir wollen die Westen zurück!"
Sie hat aber nicht gemerkt, dass wir
gar nie gelernt haben zu schwimmen.
Bevor man den Menschen
die Schwimmwesten wegnimmt,
muss man ihnen dasSchwimmen
beibringen - sonst ertrinken sie.
I think that's enough medicine.
Yes, we go home.
Jo hat meine Barramundis gekocht.
Welches ist das beste Stück?
Für dich? Das Filetstück.
Warum für mich?
Meine Kinder und ich
essen den Kopf und den Schwanz.
Der Kopf ist
fürden ältesten Mann am Tisch
und der Schwanz
für die älteste Frau.
Darum habe ich dir vorher gesagt:
"Sag nicht überstürzt,
welches Stück du möchtest."
Denn im Lauf deines Lebens
wirst du den ganzen Fisch essen.
Du fängst beim Schwanz an
und endest beim Kopf.
Alles zu seiner Zeit
und nichts überstürzt.
Wenn jemand bettelt und sagt,
er will dies oder jenes,
dann bekommt er es erst recht nicht.
Dann gebe ich dir also den Kopf?
Ja.
Simon, willst du einen Kopf?
Den grossen oder den kleinen?
Nimm du den grossen, Papa!
Nein, ich nehme den kleinen.
Danke, Sven.
You're welcome.
Perfect!
Some chili and some lemon here.
Jo, du bist als weisse Australierin
mit einem Aborigine verheiratet.
Wie hast du all diese Regeln gelernt?
Das war ein langsamer Prozess.
Nevilles Familie
hat mich sehr herzlich aufgenommen
und mich auch akzeptiert.
Sie haben nie gesagt:
"So musst du es machen!"
Sie gaben mir Zeit zu lernen,
v.a. indem sie mir Dinge zeigten.
Ich war manchmal
etwas schwer von Begriff.
Aber sie waren
geduldig und grosszügig.
Und natürlich
konnte Neville mir helfen,
z.B. bei den Tischmanieren,
die ungewohnt waren.
Wisst ihr noch, was wir
in der Schweiz sagen vor dem Essen?
En Guete!
Okay, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Mmh!
Es ist ein anderes Essen, wenn man
es selbst gefangen hat - sehr fein.
Jo ist übrigens
eine exzellente Köchin,
wir werden verwöhnt
nach Strich und Faden.
Mit unseren 2 Barramundis haben
wir unseren Teil dazu beigetragen.
Heitere Banjo-Musik
Neville Poelina hat den Sprung
in die moderne Welt geschafft,
ohne seine Traditionen aufzugeben -
er ist eine Ausnahme.
Viele Aborigines finden sich in ihrem
eigenen Land nicht mehr zurecht.
Für sie muss der Ausdruck
Lucky Country wie ein Hohn klingen.
Lockere Gitarrenmusik
Ich fahre der Westküste entlang
nach Exmouth.
Vor der Küste
liegt das Ningaloo Reef.
Es ist mindestens so schön
wie das Great Barrier Reef
und noch viel besser intakt.
Ich bin mit der Meeresbiologin
Dani Rob verabredet.
Sie arbeitet für die Nationalpark-
behörde des Ningaloo Reef.
Sie ist zuständig für den Schutz
der riesigen Walhaie, die dort leben.
You must be Dani.
Yes, you must be Sven.
Great. What a welcome!
Nice to meet you.
Pünktlich zum Sonnenuntergang.
Ja, das ist
unser Lieblingsplatz hier oben.
Wir haben bereits einige Wale
vorbeischwimmen gesehen.
Von hier oben?
Toll, und dazu Barbecue
mit Freunden und Familie?
Ja, wir treffen uns
zu Garnelen und Champagner
und halten Ausschau nach den Walen.
Cheers! Thank you very much.
No problem. Thank you for coming.
Dani hat mich eingeladen, sie morgen
bei ihrer Arbeit zu begleiten.
Mit etwas Glück kann ich
auch mit Walhaien schwimmen.
Am nächsten Morgen liegen
vor der Küste einige Ausflugsboote.
In Exmouth haben sich in den letzten
Jahren einige Tourismusunternehmen
auf die Vermarktung
der Walhaie spezialisiert.
Alle:
Good morning!
Die Konkurrenz
unter den Touristenbooten ist gross.
Umso wichtiger sind Kontrollen.
Dani begleitet regelmässig
Walhai-Ausflüge und kontrolliert,
ob die Richtlinien
eingehalten werden.
Jedes Boot braucht eine Lizenz
und ist einem strikten
Verhaltenskodex unterstellt.
Obwohl das Wasser angenehm warm ist,
bekomme ich einen Neoprenanzug -
zum Schutz vor der australischen
Sonne und den saisonalen Quallen.
Danis oberstes Ziel
ist der Schutz der Walhaie.
Der Kapitän des Touristenboots
will mit der Vermarktung der Haie
Geld verdienen.
Als Dani seine Papiere kontrolliert,
ist die Stimmung
locker und freundschaftlich.
Doch Dani ist der Boss hier.
Entdeckt sie Verstösse
gegen die Richtlinien,
kann der Veranstalter
seine Lizenz verlieren.
Meine Nervosität steigt.
Ein Flugzeug sucht Walhaie
und meldet dem Kapitän
die genaue Position.
Auch wir Schnorchler
müssen Regeln einhalten:
Wir dürfen uns dem Hai
nur von hinten nähern,
damit er ungehindert
weiterschwimmen kann.
Und wir müssen einen Mindestabstand
von 4 m einhalten.
Und da ist er,
nur wenige Meter von mir entfernt.
Sphärische Klänge
Der Walhai
ist der grösste Fisch der Weltmeere.
Die Begegnung ist kurz.
Mit einem einzigen Flossenschlag
tauchte der Riese ab in
die Dunkelheit des Indischen Ozeans.
Ich habe einen gesehen,
aber nur ganz kurz.
Er war sehr schnell unterwegs.
Ich sah ihn nur kurz durch
die Sonneneinstrahlung schimmern.
Ja, ich habe ihn gesehen,
aber nur kurz.
War wohl ein schneller Kerl.
Ja, ziemlich schnell.
Walhaie sind Einzelgänger
und wandern entlang der Küste.
Dani überwacht,
dass die Touristenboote nicht
zu lange beim gleichen Tier bleiben.
Der Kapitän muss
immer wieder andere Haie ansteuern,
die seine Helfer erspäht haben.
Wann hast du
deinen ersten Walhai gesehen?
Vor etwa 10 Jahren.
Und das war der Moment, in dem du
dich in die Tiere verliebt hast?
Diese Tiere haben mich
schon in der Schule fasziniert.
Aber ich hätte mir nie erträumt,
dass ich dereinst im Ningaloo Reef
mit ihnen arbeiten werde.
Als 12-Jährige
konnte ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Es ist fantastisch.
Ich finde,
sie sind mehr Wale als Haie.
Nein, das meinen alle.
Sie sind richtige Haie
und nicht mit dem Wal verwandt.
Aber der Charakter scheint so ruhig.
Wenn wir sie sehen,
sind sie nicht auf Nahrungssuche.
Sie wärmen sich gemütlich
an der Meeresoberfläche auf.
Ich habe die Walhaie schon
in gefrässiger Ekstase erlebt,
wenn sie hungrig waren.
Sie schiessen
mit offenem Maul durchs Wasser.
Dann willst du auf keinen Fall
in ihrer Nähe sein.
Nicht weil sie angreifen würden,
aber sie sind
so schnell und kräftig,
du könntest ihnen kaum ausweichen.
Ein 2. Walhai ist aufgetaucht.
Dort drüben dreht er seine Runden.
Ein wenig kribblig bin ich schon,
das sind ziemlich grosse Goldfische.
Sphärische Klänge
Obwohl Walhaie so imposant sind,
weiss man sehr wenig
über ihre Wanderrouten
und ihr Paarungsverhalten.
Dani vermutet,
dass sie einen grossen Teil ihres
Lebens in grosser Tiefe verbringen.
Die Meeresbiologin
kommt auch ins Wasser,
um die Rückenflosse des Hais
zu fotografieren.
Sie ist bei jedem Tier individuell.
Dani kann die Tiere identifizieren
und so die Population kontrollieren.
Sphärische Klänge
Jetzt habe ich ihn gesehen.
Etwa 4 m, ein eher kleinerer Walhai,
aber sehr schön.
Bei aller Faszination
und Begeisterung -
mir geht es gar nicht gut.
Kommst du nochmals rein?
Nein? Okay.
Nein, mir ist schlecht.
Ich bin eben doch ein Bergler
und nicht wirklich seetauglich.
Mein Tag ist gelaufen -
und ich träume von Walhaien.
Sphärische Klänge
Am nächsten Morgen
habe ich mich erholt.
Inzwischen stehen 11'493 km
auf dem Zähler.
Ich reise weiter
entlang der Westküste.
Zum Sonnenaufgang am nächsten Morgen
erreiche ich die berühmten Pinnacles.
Jetzt sind wir also
bei den Pinnacles.
Faszinierend, es sieht aus
wie eine Unterwasserlandschaft.
Heller Sand und Riffe.
Spitzen, die aus dem Boden ragen.
Diese Kalksteinsäulen
entstanden vor Tausenden von Jahren.
Damals lag all dies
tatsächlich unter Wasser.
Schau dir mal dieses Bild an!
Sanfte Klänge
Meine Reise
neigt sich langsam dem Ende zu.
Ich bin
seit über 2 Monaten unterwegs.
Solche Bilder nehme ich mit,
und sie bleiben unvergessen.
Ich frage mich:
Wie werden die Menschen geprägt,
die in solch endlos scheinenden
Landschaften aufwachsen?
Aus meiner Heimat kenne ich die
Geborgenheit inmitten hoher Berge.
Nach 12'378 km endet meine Reise.
Vor 10 Wochen bin ich mit meinem Team
in der Bruthitze des Outbacks
gestartet.
Ich muss mich voll konzentrieren,
dass ich links bleibe.
Alles ist verkehrt.
Ich war zum ersten Mal in Australien
und wollte herausfinden,
was dran ist an der Behauptung,
nirgends lebe man so glücklich
wie im Lucky Country.
Sanfte Klänge
Ich lernte Menschen kennen, die mich
mit ihrer Leidenschaft ansteckten.
Und ich lernte Menschen kennen,
die mir zeigten,
dass man das Glück
in den kleinen Dingen suchen muss.
Sind die Menschen in Australien
glücklicher als wir in der Schweiz?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Mir erweiterte diese Reise -
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes -
meinen Horizont.
Und ich weiss jetzt:
Wer die Offenheit und den Mut hat
zu verreisen, gewinnt die Chance,
den Wert des eigenen Lucky Country
neu zu entdecken.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
2014 / bearbeitet 2021